bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat pour suivre ce matin deux
auditions celle de nicolas hulot par la
commission des affaires étrangères au
sénat
l'émissaire auprès du président de la
république sur la protection de la
planète en vue de la conférence paris
climat 2015 sera entendu autour de 11h30
par cette commission des affaires
étrangères du sénat mais d'abord je vous
propose de découvrir celle de loïs bono
par la commission denquête au sénat sur
l'éducation et la perte de repères
républicains pour vous resituer cette
commission denquête elle a été créée à
la fin du mois de janvier au lendemain
des attentats meurtriers qui ont frappé
la france et à la demande du groupe ump
son but est bien faire ou refaire de
l'école le creuset des valeurs de la
république et comprendre les difficultés
rencontrées par les enseignants dans
l'exercice de leur métier
on va s'intéresser ce matin à cette
dernière question les enseignants avec
l'audition de loïs bono professeur de
lettres classiques au lycée chaptal à
paris
il dresse un constat édifiant sur le
niveau actuel des élèves et le fossé qui
se creuse entre la france et ses élèves
tout de suite on découvre son diagnostic
et ses propositions en audition comme la
loi le permet votre audition fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié dans le
recueil des travaux des commissions qui
est diffusé en version papier sur le
site du sénat
professeur certifié de lettres vous
enseigner dans le secondaire depuis plus
de 15 ans aujourd'hui au lycée chaptal à
paris
vous avez exercé pendant plusieurs
années dans des collèges situés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire notamment à
marceau et à sarcelles vous êtes
également l'auteur d'un blogue intitulé
la vie moderne que vous décrivez vous
même comme une chronique de l'école
moderne ainsi que deux tribunes sur le
site de l'hebdomadaire marianne
défenseurs de l'école républicaine vous
décriez l'excès de pédagogisme prôné un
retour à l'enseignement des fondamentaux
et regretté la perte d'autorité des
enseignants la commission
a souhaité vous entendre pour recueillir
votre avis sur l'état de la transmission
des valeurs républicaines à l'école et
des difficultés rencontrées par les
enseignants dans leurs églises dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions vous
pourrez sans doute éclairer nos travaux
à la lumière de votre expérience
d'enseignant et en tant que spécialiste
de la question scolaire sur les
solutions à mettre en oeuvre pour
restaurer la fonction première de
l'école former les citoyens de la
république avant de vous passer la
parole monsieur le formalisme des
commission denquête me conduit à vous
demander de prêter serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant une
autre commission serait passible des
peines prévues aux articles 4 54 13 à
434 15 du code pénal en conséquence je
vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité levé
la main droite et dit je le jure je le
jure je vous remercie
selon l' usage habituel je vous propose
de nous faire part de vos observations
durant une dizaine de minutes après quoi
notre reporter jacques grosperrin et les
membres de la commission qui le
souhaitent pourront vous poser leurs
questions
vous avez la parole je vous remercie
madame le président de m'avoir invité
mais sur un porteur messieurs mesdames
les sénateurs alors je vous demande
votre bienveillance parce que j'ai
effectivement pas pu construire un
couple très conséquent très construit
donc ça sera peut-être un petit peu
confus j'espère que ça ne sera pas trop
nous avons tous été saisi par les
événements du 7 janvier
mais en réalité nous avons été saisis
par l'ampleur mais les professeurs n'ont
pas été surpris ils connaissent ces
réactions qui sont celles des élèves
dont on entend parler depuis longtemps
dès le 2 août et par exemple 11
septembre 2001 ou lors des émeutes de
2005 n'ont pu vivre des événements
analogues
et puis nous les vivons au quotidien
j'ai moi même vécu une émeute dans un
collège de province donc ce sont des
choses qui sont que nous connaissons
bien c'est à dire ce sentiment que de
france coexistent se regarde sans se
connaître et évidemment on ne peut pas
imaginer que les causes soient
uniquement scolaire néanmoins notre
responsabilité puisque celle de cette
commission c'est de voir dans quelle
mesure l'école peut apporter
des solutions ce qui semble s'être
fracturé terrible finalement dans notre
république
je suis content que des pauvres je suis
heureux que des professeurs puissent
être entendus je regarde que finalement
enfin j'ai pas vu que dans le des
instituteurs avaient été invités donc si
jamais vous pouvez inviter les
instituteurs
c'est prévu d'accord je l'en félicite
des professeurs de lycée professionnel
également je vous recommande si vous le
pouvez que nous ne soyons pas uniquement
des professeurs du secondaire
disons classique être représenté l'école
ici bien entendu alors que constatons
nous nous constatons effectivement
depuis très longtemps en fait grâce à
cette à ces événements un finalement une
sorte qu'ils vivent est une sorte de
lumière sur l'école
donc profitons de cette lumière que
j'étais sur l'école pour avoir un moment
de lucidité
c'est ça la lucidité c'est la lumière
regardons ce que devient notre école
regardons ce qu'elle est devenue depuis
longtemps observons analysons soyons
francs soyons polémique en disant les
choses clairement et franchement nous
avons en face de nous des élèves qui
sont maintenant dans des difficultés
pour s'exprimer
pour lire pour comprendre et pas
seulement des élèves de l'école primaire
mes élèves du secondaire du collège et
même du lycée
je pourrais vous donner si vous
souhaitez par la suite tous les chiffres
intéressants à ce sujet pour vous donner
un exemple un seul exemple dans les
études pisa on s'aperçoit qui est à peu
près 7% ça paraît pas beaucoup 7% 7 %
des élèves de 15 ans 16 ans qui n'ont
pas les compétences de lecture des
élèves de primaire voilà donc on cherche
un petit peu où va se loger finalement
cette incompréhension de la république
elle commence peut-être ici c'est sa
touche malheureusement pas uniquement
des publics défavorisés mais c'est
l'école toute entière à moi j'ai pu j'ai
d'enseignants différents postes donc
j'ai pu constater que dans les collèges
les plus défavorisés dans les lycées les
plus favorisés une sorte de délitement
de déliquescence de la compréhension de
l'écrit tout simplement de la phase de
l'expression de l'expression écrite de
l'expression orale et même de la graphie
maintenant on en est là c'est ce que je
vous demande d'aller constater sur mon
site notamment j'étais tellement frappé
par ça que j'ai scanné des copies de mes
élèves en 2006 parce que la graphie et
le même pose problème avec des élèves
qui peuvent avoir 15
17 18 ans qui ne savent pas écrire de
manière régulière on en est là il faut
que les gens ouvrent les yeux maintenant
alors évidemment quand on n'a pas cette
culture de l'écrit quand on n'a pas
cette capacité à comprendre on s'expose
à évidemment à ne pas avoir l'autonomie
de pensée qui est évidemment de
l'objectif de l'école émancipée et on
est en quelque sorte a servi toute autre
forme de pensée qui semble présenter une
forme d'unité pour laquelle sur laquelle
on pourra pas exercer un esprit critique
il faut réfléchir par exemple à
l'extraordinaire implicite de
l'expression je suis charlie c'est comme
une expression qui compliquait qui a
beaucoup d'implicite je suis charlie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il faut pas
s'étonner que les élèves qui a reçu en
pleine poire excusez moi l'expression
mais cette expression est une sorte de
rebellions vis-à-vis de cette expression
je me suis identifié moi même c'était
une sorte de d'émotion collective bien
entendu mais il faut pas tellement
s'étonner que les élèves ne puissent pas
comprendre tout l'implicite de cette
expression je suis charlie de la même
manière dont il ya d'une part tout part
de la part des élèves une sorte
d'incompréhension et je dirais de la
part des autorités il ya eu également
une incompréhension cette injonction
ce que je suis charlie ça ressemble à
une injonction a finalement et puis
réussie de l'injonction de la minute de
silence
il faut pas tellement s'étonner que
cette décision ait été à mes yeux un
petit peu maladroite témoignant d une
méconnaissance des publics qui sont les
déshérités comme disait françois xavier
bellamy il va falloir que l'on fasse ce
qu'on puisse s'en temps qu'on puisse
comprendre et les enseignants sont là
pour ça ils font le lien entre les gens
qui prennent des décisions et puis les
enfants qui sont en quelque sorte au
bout de la ligne
alors je représente ici ne nous leurrons
pas un camp dans le grand combat qui est
celui de l'école parce qu'il ya une
grande division une grande fracture en
école elle est terrible elle est
attristante on peut tous le regretter il
y a effectivement un débat que l'on
cherche souvent occulté un pour une
unité promouvoir une sorte d' unité de
façade entre donc républicain ce qu'on
appelle républicain et puis les
pédagogues bien sûr nous sommes tous
républicains
bien sûr nous sommes tous pédagogue ça
les termes sont évidemment très mal
choisi
qu'est ce qu'on entend en fait par
républicains d'être une mise au point
lexical très rapide les républicains se
sont simplement ce
qui sont en quelque sorte reconnaissant
de la tradition républicaine de l'école
rien de plus reconnaissant cette
tradition pas admirateurs pas cultive
une cultivant pas une sorte d'adoration
d'une école idéale qui n'a jamais existé
mais reconnaissant dans cette école qui
a pu les lycées par exemple à devenir
eux mêmes des professeurs par exemple
c'est mon corps le cas de nombreux
professeurs c'est une l'école est encore
un lieu de l'ascenseur social au moins
pour certaines populations devenir
professeur c'est encore un idéal voyez
c'est quelque chose de très très très
beau et donc je reviens cette grande
fracture qui est celle des républicains
et des pédagogues 7 cette bataille qui a
lieu en réalité elle est perdue je suis
je suis je viens ici en perdant
nous avons perdu nous perdons depuis 10
20 30 40 ans nous sommes en 2015
le collège unique a été mis en place en
donc si nous fêtons cette année les 40
ans du collège unique félicitons-nous
d'avoir eu cette intention je ne fais
pas partie des gens qui réclament le
retour en arrière mais faisons de bilan
pourquoi ça n'a pas fonctionné
pourquoi tous ces enfants que nous avons
voulu amener au collège et dont nous
avons eu la noble ambition que nous
avons une obligation de remis au collège
pourquoi nous n'avons pas pu en faire
des êtres autonome des êtres avec une
pensée construite structurés qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi avons-nous
failli faisons d'abord le constat de
cette faillite
ne nous leurrons pas alors c'est vrai
que si on regarde un petit peu si on
écoute un peu les discours qui ont été
prononcées pendant des années on a été
plutôt dans le déni pendant très
longtemps ça a été le déni le niveau
monte
souvenez-vous même encore au début des
années 2000 et puis il ya eu des voix
qui sont qui se sont élevées et puis
maintenant même le camp on appelle
pédagogue
verse dans le catastrophisme et alors là
ça devient saisissant bien entendu tout
le monde personne ne sait ce qu'il faut
faire et arriver dans la solution qui
est proposé à c'est ce que j'appellerais
mois des dérivés que je vais essayer de
constater par la suite ça a été d'aller
encore plus loin
c'est à dire de tout ce qu'ils avaient
échoué afin d'appliquer de manière
encore plus extrême qu'est ce qui a
échoué alors jeudi à d'abord pour être
un peu polémique parce qu'on parle
souvent d'une école qui manque de
cohérence dans son action dans l'action
politique en fonction des alternances en
réalité moi je vois plutôt une
permanence dans l'action politique que
ce soit de droite ou de gauche je pense
que d'ailleurs l'idéal républicain que
je représente ici n'est ni de droite ni
de gauche
et j'observe cette permanence parce que
j'observe dans des détails très précis
par exemple la réforme du lycée qui a
été acceptée aussi bien par la droite
par la gauche que par la gauche dans des
dents des landais par exemple le fait
d'avoir réduit la voix prochaine à 4 en
bas 3 ans n'a pas été ce soap sam n'a
pas été remis en cause par le changement
de majorité dont on voit qu'il ya une
sorte de permanence politique et cette
alliance politique elle va plus loin que
dans les pieds de mesures de détail
comme celle que j'évoquais à l'instant
elle va dans par exemple cette idée de
d'ouverture de l'école voilà on parlait
tout à l'heure aux ceintures irisation
il faut ouvrir l'école en réalité nous
avons pratiqué l'enfermement en voulant
ouvrir l'école nous avons pratiqué
l'enfermement en voulant renoncer à
instruire en voulant renoncer à porter
la langue française en voulant renoncer
à apporter la culture a apporté
l'histoire à apporter toutes les
connaissances
évidemment je suis un peu caricatural
encore jeudi que nous renonçons tous les
professeurs nous essayons nous évertuons
continuer à essayer de le faire mais je
regarde un petit peu ce qu'on nous
demande maintenant on nous demande d'y
renoncer
et je peux vous détailler de quelle
façon façon très précise
puisqu'on a constaté que les cov était
en faillite il a fallu maintenant
trouver enfin constater que le collège
unique ne fonctionnait pas il a fallu
trouver des raisons alors on n'a pas
analysé les vraies raisons de l'échec
mais on a trouvé d'autres raisons on
s'est aperçu que ben voilà on ne
construisait pas comme une falaise on
éduque et pas comme il fallait donc on a
inventé
enfin ça fait très longtemps maintenant
on a remis en place dix ont une
entreprise de déconstruction de l'école
si on observe çà c'est assez saisissant
la déconstruction de l'école bizarrement
elle passe par une notion qui est celle
du constructivisme qui a déjà été abordé
à votre dans votre devant une commission
par françois-xavier bellamy le
construite le constructivisme c'est
l'idée que l'enfant doit apprendre à
apprendre doit apprendre au sol avec le
professeur n'est plus qu'un guide un
accompagnateur médiateur on a rencontré
on a fixé comme objectif de l objectif
est en quelque sorte le refus du
magistral le refus de la classe même du
principe même de la classe je vous
invite à consulter des revendications de
fédérations de parents d'élèves le refus
de l'effort au fond le plaisir c'est
inscrit dans les programmes de deux
collèges le plaisir le mot plaisir est
revenu à de nombreuses reprises elle
pointe de collège depuis les années 1990
et de plaisir tout le monde est d'accord
avec cette idée le plaisir et le plaisir
non pas un plaisir qui précède les
formes et qui en procède ce qui change
tout ouais c'est ça qui ferait revenir
ce sur quoi il faudrait revenir on a
accusé des vies dans l'école d'élitisme
on a voulu la ludi chier la rendre
ludique
évidemment on a abandonné l'idée
d'autorité je pourrais vous donner de
nombreux exemples de cet abandon de
l'autorité et puis surtout on a créé de
faux débats en quelque sorte tous ces
faux débats dont hong kong grandi sous
le nez depuis des années et des années
alors je les exemples les plus récents
évidemment il ya toujours l'idée que la
formation des enseignants les
enseignants sont jamais bien formés
jamais assez fort mais jamais comme il
faudrait bien entendu ça c'est tout le
monde sera d'accord là dessus sachant
que le mot formation ne veut rien dire
en tant que telle il faut y réfléchir on
a par exemple considérer que l'école
n'était pas assez bienveillante
récemment que la notation était un
problème que finir l'école à 16h30
c'était forcément une forme de
traumatismes et qu'il fallait tout ça
devait éclater tout ça devait changer
ce sont évidemment de faux problème il
fallait apprendre l'anglais très tôt un
âge même où les enfants ne maîtrisent
pas leur propre langue
ils ne maîtrisent pas leurs premiers il
faut avoir le courage de le dire tout ça
on a accusé d' écoles d'organiser une
forme de ségrégation
c'est vrai qu'il ya des inégalités
terrible à l'école c'est vrai on va dans
certains collèges et on observe on le
voit bien sûr mais ce n'est pas l'école
qui et ségrégatives ce n'est pas elle 1
c'est autre chose c'est ce qu'elles
n'apportent plus kiffé ségrégation et là
il va falloir réfléchir à cette question
là de manière précise
1 c'est pas en faisant des conventions
c'est pas sciences po par exemple qu'on
va créer de l'égalité en réalité on crée
une inégalité factice je vous donne un
exemple
donc tout ça ce sont des exemples dans
quelque sorte de faux débat qui nous
empêche de voir ce qui devrait être un
vrai débat donc je vais y venir très
vite il va falloir voir comprendre à
quel point l'école est en quelque sorte
dans le déni du réel
ça serait la première chose une prise de
conscience un j'entendais notre ministre
dit récemment que l'école était dans une
impasse
or nous avons un baccalauréat qui est
obtenu par une proportion record d'une
génération record inégalé dans
l'histoire de la république 77 4 % d'une
génération a son bac aujourd'hui c'est
merveilleux mais comment concilier cette
cette réussite merveilleuse avec
l'impasse qu'on nous présente par
ailleurs nous sommes donc dans une forme
de schizophrénie
cette schizophrénie on peut la
rencontrer partout le niveau qui
montrent le redoublement qui est
supprimé les examens donc qui n'ont plus
de valeur en soi
les appréciations qui sont supprimés sur
les bulletins des élèves les élèves ne
savent plus eux-mêmes ce qu'ils doivent
penser ils sont
et croyez moi ils ne sont pas dupes ils
ne sont pas dupes de ce qu'on essaie de
leur faire croire c'est à dire leur
faire croire une réussite factice
factice fictive a emmené dans la
l'illusion la fiction de la réussite
scolaire puisqu'on n'a pas réussi une
vraie n'a pas réussi une vraie
démocratisation de l'école on va faire
semblant
non ne faisons pas semblant ayant tout
cet objectif nous devons nous accrocher
à cette idée
cette égalité des chances mais pas une
égalité des chances qu'il soit une
égalité de façade pas une égalité des
chances qui suppose que tout le monde
réussisse à égalité à la fin ça n'est
pas possible ça dépendrait ce qu'on
entend par réussite
si cette réussite c'est de se sentir
appartenir la république oui ça c'est la
vraie égalité des chances et que tout le
monde puisse se sentir appartenir à
cette république
mais une égalité des chances qu'ils
soient évidemment une égalité des
chances au départ nous devons lutter
contre la reproduction sociale
nous devons lutter contre les inégalités
bien entendu mais pour cela il va
falloir que l'école prenne à bras le
corps la difficulté scolaire au lieu
d'entrer dans cette de créer ce déni
dont les élèves ne sont pas dupes et qui
crée chez eux une immense frustration
alors les vrais débats il serait très
nombreux je voudrais certainement des
questions par la suite
évidemment il ya le regard qui est porté
sur l'enseignant d'une manière générale
déconsidérer pas de si bien payé que ça
mal soutenu mal finalement toujours
accusé d'être mal formés on accuse de
vouloir travailler tout seul mais c'est
toute la dignité du métier d'enseignant
de travailler seul
je le revendique hautement vouloir
m'obliger à travailler en équipe
c'est considérer que je suis insuffisant
comme professeur je ne suis pas
insuffisant
je suis un professeur de la république
j'ai ma dignité de professeurs de la
pluie et les élèves doit le savoir
doivent le savoir regardons ce qui s'est
passé avec le collège unique pour
prendre un exemple très simple et puis
je vais essayer de pas trop traîner nous
avons en permettant à tous les élèves
d'entrer dans le collège unique diminuer
le nombre d'heures de français qu'il
aurait été prodigués nous l'avons
diminué quand nous avons voulu conduire
des publics qui était si éloigné du
collège nous aurions dû faire un effort
immense pour ses enfants pour ces
publics
nous avons fait le contraire et si vous
regardez cette diminution
elle commence en 1975 c'est l'année où
je suis née et elle n'a fait que
continuer nous sommes actuellement dans
les basses eaux des horaires de français
de la république
les basses eaux j'ai des chiffres eux si
vous voulez très rapidement un élève
alors je veux faire de mémoire un élève
de 3e 4e aujourd'hui qui sort de l'école
enfin qu'il serait en 4e aujourd'hui
finalement a eu autant d'heures de
français qu'un élève qui sortait de cm2
je sais pas si vous réalisez ces trois
ans qui sont perdus trois ans laury
dance à ses succès du quantitatif il n'y
a pas que quantitatif il ya évidemment
les la façon d'enseigner un les
modalités pratiques les professeurs en
plus de place donc plus d'élèves donc
plus de devoirs à corriger il va falloir
évidemment quand on diminue le nom de
l'horreur d'un élève ne se rend pas
compte de ça mais quand une profession
rencontre on a plus de classe on peut on
est moins disponible pour les élèves
tout en recevant l'injonction de
personnaliser son enseignement
et puis il ya la façon d'enseigner bien
entendu toutes les nouvelles pédagogies
qui nous ont qui ont occasionné une
façon de déconstruire l'école je
pourrais revenir là dessus si ça vous
intéresse qui font que ben on a organisé
la faillite
on a organisé la faillite on a créé un
échec scolaire artificiel en france
faisant le constat observons le
regardons le lucidement les mesures que
nous prenons actuellement qui sont
prises actuellement par le gouvernement
mais à mes yeux il ne fait que continuer
ce qui a été entrepris auparavant ne me
rassure pas inquiète
nous sommes dans la détestation des
disciplines nous sommes dans les
atteintes à la liberté pédagogique
nous ne pouvons pas attiré dans ce
métier des professeurs
si nous en faisons des ouvriers nous ne
pourrons pas il faut que les élèves
alors c'est une phrase rhétorique bien
entendu mais il faut que les élèves qui
sont des sortes déshérités puisse avoir
de nouveaux espoirs dans l'école qui ne
se sentent ni se sentent pas dupe il ne
semble pas que les collégiens est un
piège est un leurre on va entretenir le
plus longtemps possible le plus loin
possible en fixant des objectifs qui
deviennent maintenant il réaliste la
scolarité obligatoire est quasiment
maintenant fixé à 18 ans dans les faits
les objectifs que nous nous fixons
suivant est de 50 % des élèves au niveau
licence mais que n'aura que nous
valorisons nous parler les études
professionnelles courtes
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi un
baccalauréat professionnel serait-il
moins valorisants qu'un baccalauréat
général reconsidérons notre école
n'ayant pas qu'un seul objectif ne nous
fixons pas l'égalité des chances en nous
disant que la seule façon de réussite
c'est d'obtenir un bac général est de
continuer dans les études générales non
ce n'est pas vrai c'est totalement faux
il faut évidemment prouver le réseau
apprécié n est pas uniquement pour les
déshérités pour tout ce qu'on puisse
d'où qu'on vienne faire un bac
professionnel sans être déshonoré bref
aux j'abrège c'est presque fini
laissons le temps à l'école parce que
c'est pas des mesures qui vont être des
mesures de kounoune mal de petits coups
des petites mesures qui vont changer
grand chose
on sait très bien que quand on ne la
changera pas en deux ans en trois ans en
cinq ans si on veut vraiment changer
lecteurs il va falloir se perd semaine
dans une perspective de 10 ans 15 ans
peut être plus sans doute plus le temps
scolaire n'est pas le temps médiatique
où le temps politique
il faut en avoir conscience faisons
preuve de lucidité
considérant que l'école ne peut pas tout
mais elle peut beaucoup merci pour ce
propos liminaire intéressant tonique
j'aurais dit même voire provocateur par
certains moments mais c'est ce qui
permettra à notre rapporteur déjà de
vous poser quelques questions et à nos
collègues aussi merci oui merci merci de
dire les choses en tout cas des choses
que vous ressentez je crois que tout le
monde ne ressent pas les mêmes choses
mais je crois que c'est important de le
dire parce que ça suscite le débat
vous savez vous parler des difficultés
au collège lycée moi je peux vous dire
l'université j'étais ancienne à
l'université ouailles et des copies
adversité mais c'est catastrophique ce
que vous pouvez dire vous demandez à un
moment donné lire écrire et c'est à
l'heure a sonné dans le déni puis on dit
non tout va bien parce qu'on en arrive à
ce cadre et sur un étudiant qui va bien
ou soit on est la réalité
puis on se rend compte que 70 % des
étudiants n'arrivent plus à écrire
correctement à l'université collège
unique
on a changé l'énoncé des collèges pour
tous sa réussite pour tous ce que laisse
ouverte vers la vie etc
on croit je faisais souvent l'exemple
d'un sur l'exemple sur le sport on croit
que m des faibles et des forts ensemble
on va permettre aux faibles d'être
meilleurs pros ford est encore meilleur
non en réalité l'effort deviennent de
plus en plus fort et puis les faibles
deviennent de plus en plus faible parce
que la distance d'un cours ou alors on
baisse le niveau d'exigence du court
donc il ya beaucoup de choses par
rapport à ça il faut quand même en me
donniez dans la qualité peut enfin avant
de poser trois questions
je crois que vous avez raison de dire le
pédagogisme et je crois que je citerai
pas la personne mais qui est enseignant
du côté de lyon qui avait un écho très
favorable dans le cadre des enseignants
du primaire du primaire et qui a trompé
les enseignants en mettant en parlant de
révolution copernicienne de mettre
l'élève l'enfant au centre du processus
éducatif et on ne parlait plus des
matières fallait que l'enfant soit bien
soit heureux
etc je crois qu'on a une responsabilité
tous mais et puis peut-être que la
stabilité ou si elle vient vous l'avez
dit de tous les gouvernements politiques
de droite comme de gauche qui à un
moment donné on va accepter ce
délitement par rapport à cela et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est le rôle de
cette commission c'est de réfléchir à
cela et on l'entend souvent chez les uns
chez les autres sur le trail des grands
dieux su revenir sur la notion d'effort
etc
mais je pense que mes collègues pour des
questions vis-à-vis de cela le très
rapidement est-ce que vous pensez que
lundi gradation du climat scolaire et si
oui est-ce que la perte d'autorité
enseignants elle défaut discipline à
l'école vous paraît style pouvoir
l'expliquer j'oublie ce prix là
la deuxième question certains
enseignants nous ont affirmé ne pas se
sentir suffisamment préparés voire
parfois soutenues par leur hiérarchie
vis-à-vis de la contestation des valeurs
républicaines
comment les accompagner dans la
formation dans leur mission de formation
des citoyens
et puis de manière générale comment
l'école tels transmettre les valeurs
républicaines
est ce que le contenu des enseignements
à l'organisation de la vie scolaire au
sein des établissements vous semble-t-il
adapté puis à peut-être une question sur
le rôle des parents comment les associer
peut-être plus directement à tout cela
alors alors pour le plus vite possible
pour revenir à part dont vous d'accord
sur la discipline à 1
un élément qui est on a beaucoup parlé
de pisa du niveau scolaire etc
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur
pisane bien entendu mais disons qu'il ya
un facteur que j'ai relevées en lisant
très attentivement le rapport pisa 2012
qui n'est évoquée par personne c'est que
la france a un des pires climats de
discipline de l'oscd eu un des pires
nous sommes 59e si je me souviens bien
sûr 64 ce qui signifie quand on me pose
alors ça si c'est une enquête on pose
des questions aux élèves
combien de temps le court vous met-il a
commencé est ce que le professeur est
écouté et c'est ce genre de questions et
on s'aperçoit que en france le climat de
discipline est catastrophique
donc évidemment tous les professeurs en
ont fait l'expérience notamment les
établissements difficiles
pas besoin d'aller rapport pisa pour ça
c'est vous mettez dix minutes a commencé
votre cour importe quel interruption ne
vous empêche de souffrir copains en 10
minutes et puis au total finalement
entre le moment où vous avez voulu
commencer à vraiment à faire votre
prénom ou là vous avez pu le faire à
s'écouler peut-être une demi heure sur
une heure de cours ce qui était risqué
terry puisqu'on parlait des horaires
mais il ya aussi la réalité de la
pratique concrètement comment ça se
passe donc évidemment dans ces
conditions là il faut s'interroger
je veux pas partie des gens qui sont
pour une école du père fouettard bien
entendu on n'est pas je suis pas du tout
étonnant des retours aux châtiments
corporels ou je ne sais quoi mais
simplement que nous prenions conscience
qu à force de laisser les professeurs de
les abandonner
ça c'est classe nous avons créé ce
climat nous avons créé cette ségrégation
c'était pour la première question pour
répondre brièvement justement le soutien
des enseignants
j'ai pu constater quand j'étais
enseignant dans des établissements
difficiles à quel point le soutien des
enseignants est un facteur qui change
tout l'établissement dans lequel je suis
resté le plus longtemps bénéficié d'un
chef d'établissement à poigne quelqu'un
qui se manifestait quelqu'un qui venait
dans la cour quelqu'un qui rencontrait
les élèves quelqu'un que les élèves
connaissaient tout simplement
il faudrait peut-être s'interroger sur
le fait que la façon de recruter nos
chefs d'établissement
certains sont parfaitement compétents et
parfaitement leur place mais la façon de
recruter ces deux chefs d'établissement
pose problème car j'ai pu en compter un
versement des pros des chefs
d'établissement qui faisait preuve d'une
grande servilité pour le dire de manière
très crue d'une grande servilité à
l'égal de leur ré à l'égard de leur
hiérarchie est dans le déni du coup dans
le déni 1 j'ai même plus je me souviens
pour vous donner une anecdote
personnelle avec l'occasion de l'émeute
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure dans
un collège j'ai reçu des coups est
proviseur la principale de cet
établissement avait dit mais comment ça
vous prétendez avoir reçu des coups mais
vous m'avez pas fait de rapport là
dessus donc vous n'avez pas reçu de
poules monsieur bruno il n'avait pas
fait de rapport dont temps je n'avais
pas fait ça n'existait pas donc on
attend d'un chef d'établissement qui
nous fasse confiance
on atteindrait chef de l'ismans qui nous
disent pas fait - rapport pour que je
vous crois on atteint la folie ce
mandant lâché le talisman qui ne me dise
pas que la voix de l'élève est légal de
la voix du maître comme j'ai pu le
rencontrer dans deux à de nombreuses
reprises et je pourrais aussi vous
donner une foule d'anecdotes à ce sujet
il va falloir abandonner qu'on se dise
que recrue des chefs de mission parce
que à mon avis dans un établissement
difficile un bon chef d'établissement
c'est déjà le début d'une remise d'une
remise en ordre
voilà quelque chose qui va pouvoir
fonctionner qu on lui donne la stabilité
qu'au bout de cinq ans chez les
établissements soient pas obligés de
changer d'établissement parce que c'est
vrai que c'est la politique actuelle
qu'on puisse c'est évidemment permettre
à des équipes d'être stable parce que si
vous voulez que les professeurs se
sentent soutenus il faut aussi se
sentent soutenus entre la stabilité
équipe est un des grands problèmes
endémiques de l'école actuelle et si
vous voulez que les équipes soient
stables il va falloir les choyer ses
équipes
il va falloir qu'elle se sente bien dans
les établissements difficiles va falloir
qu'on leur fasse par exemple une toute
petite j'ai pas une petite
remise de service quelques heures sans
exiger quoi que ce soit en contrepartie
comme on le fait actuellement en
culpabilisant ses équipes de ne pas bien
fait leur travail
il va falloir qu'on leur fasse des
aménagements d emploi du temps aménagé
pour qu'elle se sente qu'elle puisse
respirer
ce sont des établissements dans lequel
on doit pouvoir respirer on a envie d'y
rester c'est pas forcément des primes de
l'argent ou des points qui vous
permettront de partir qui permettront à
cette équipe de rester il faut que les
équipes s'y sentent bien
il faut qu'elles soient choyés ainsi
j'avais pu si j'avais ressenti tout ça
si je m'étais senti soutenu ici on
m'avait valoriser en tant que professeur
dans ces établissements sans doute au
lieu de me culpabiliser sans doute je
serais resté dans ces établissements là
sur le soutien des enseignants j'observe
aussi que depuis des années finalement
les disciples de la discipline tels que
s'établit dans l'établissement en
quelque sorte été je sais pas comment le
quel mot employer s'était trouvée
dégradé quand on a accepté des choses
qui étaient inacceptables
j'étais dans un établissement où on
pouvait préfète particulière les
particules peuvent avoir un élève qui
avait 70 rapport 70 rapport ça n'a plus
aucun sens comprenez bien qu'on est dans
le non sens alors il va falloir que je
dis pas qu'il faut les faire une école
punitive bien entendu mais il faut que
les élèves sachent ce qui se passe quand
on a un rapport un seul qu'il le sache
et je pense que les élèves ont besoin de
ça ils l'attendent il le demande
ils ont besoin de cadres tous nos
problèmes qui sont ceux de délinquance
dans le cadre des athées des
établissements scolaires ou des
incivilités pour dire les choses de
manière plus polie sont liés au fait on
a laissé faire on a habitué on a exposé
à des sanctions qui ne sont pas de
réelles sanctions
1 et on continue dans continuer à dire
certains continuent à présenter par
exemple l'exclusion définitive d'un
établissement comme une sorte de peine
de mort l'exclusion définitive dans
l'établissement c'est juste qu'on ait
affecté un autre établissement
et rien de plus rien de moins rien de
plus que l'élève sache jusqu'où ils
peuvent aller lui le sache et que les
autres le sache rien de plus 1 il c'est
pas la peine d'aller chercher de
nouvelles
des sanctions je ne sais quoi appliquons
ce que nous avons déjà dans nos mains il
ya une autre chose qui m'a toujours
choqué en tant que professeur c'est le
fait que les dossiers scolaires des
élèves sont en quelque sorte
réinitialiser chaque année un élève qui
fait brûler des poubelles en juin et
vierge en septembre c'est ahurissant
ça n'a pas de sens on doit pouvoir juger
du dossier scolaire d'un élève sur un
temps long il ya aucune raison que des
élèves puissent bénéficier d'une sorte
de mansuétude qui les autorise à
continuer dans leur incivilité j'ai pas
d'autres exemples là dessus et pour
parler de transmettre les valeurs
républicaines
bon je suis je fais partie des gens qui
pensent que l'école n'a pas vocation à
transmettre des valeurs
je pense que l'école à la vocation à
émanciper émancipé du milieu familial
émancipé d'elle-même que les élèves
deviennent des êtres autonome
l'autonomie l'autonomie de pensée
l'esprit critique la culture voilà les
éléments qui peuvent qui sont à même de
donner aux élèves le sentiment
d'appartenir à une grande république à
une un pays un vrai pays
il faut que les élèves ressentent cette
confiance dans l'école à nouveau je ne
crois pas que des courses de citoyenneté
servent à quoi que ce soit je ne crois
pas que ce genre de choses et le moindre
sens sa vérité la vérité plus et moi
presque je suis m mais je reprend la
parole parce que sur l'autorité bon je
peux entendre un certain nombre de
choses puisqu'en effet il suffit
d'appliquer les règles sur les valeurs
républicaines là j'avoue me laisser sans
voix mais dont oui oui oui c'est sa
réponse à chacun donc je passe la colle
là répond la parole à mes collègues donc
monsieur longuet demandé la parole
madame cartron
tout le monde veut la parole donc
essayer d'être bref dans vos questions
non mais si pour que monsieur puisse
répondre globalement ou individuellement
toutes les questions voilà donc monsieur
longuet je ne serai pas bref
malheureusement parce que l'intervention
de monsieur mono et passionnante et
réjouissante
donc je voudrais simplement souligner
deux grands draps diction et pose une
question les deux contradictions c'est
que vous souhaitez vous ne souhaitez pas
être un ouvrier
ce que je comprends parfaitement j'ai
bien saisi le sens de votre appel et en
même temps vous voulez être soutenu et
vous avez même utiliser un mot
affectueux choyés vous souhaitez des
dirigeants qui dirige et est donc vous
posé implicitement en réalité le la
communauté scolaire c'est-à-dire le
professeur est indépendant mais il ne
peut pas être seul et deuxièmement vous
avez fait une remarque technique très
très importante
nous n'avons pas nous avons trop de
visages en face de nous et pas assez de
suivi de chaque élève
implicitement et on les suit pas d'une
année sur l'autre ils n'ont pas
d'historique de track-record pour
prendre un mot français bien
compréhensive et donc ma question que je
vais je souhaite vous poser c'est au
fond quelle est l'organisation de
l'établissement au kivu séduirait dans
la relation entre enseignants dirigeants
et parents deuxième question et c'est
vraiment un mac à ma collègue présidente
madame laborde vous êtes vous avez une
deuxième contradiction vous dites je ne
suis pas là pour transmettre des valeurs
mais je veux émancipée sauf que pour
émanciper il faut transmettre des
valeurs
madame cartron
plusieurs réflexions si si si je
reprends le schéma d'intervention
longuet moi je dirais que votre
intervention
je la trouve attristante alors je la
trouve attristante parce que d'abord
vous nous décrivez une école en
perdition avec des élèves alors des
élèves
si j'ai entendu soit on mettez vous
manifestez déshérités qui donc sont oui
à l'abandon et des enseignants de même
donc je pense que la réalité elle est
quand même beaucoup plus nuancée ensuite
donc comme l'a dit monsieur longuet je
trouve que vous êtes plein de
contradictions
ou alors vous êtes avec un regard plein
de nostalgie par rapport à un temps béni
qui pouvaient exister il ya 50 ans où il
y avait deux âmes et vous décrivez une
autorité à maître respecté écouté
valorisé avec une vraie place dans la
société
s'il ya des choses qui sont qui sont
exactes
sauf que voilà le monde a changé et que
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas que la
nostalgie souhaite une réponse à
aujourd'hui
le changement de justement notre société
parce que vous dites oui c'est difficile
il faut faire dix minutes parfois de
deux dix de deux disciplines avant
d'enseigner la discipline mais oui mais
est-ce que vous avez vu parce que les
enfants qui rentrait dans la classe qui
s'asseyait qui ne bronchait pas
c'étaient des enfants qui dans la
famille ne prenez pas la parole à table
ne discutait pas et tout était lié rouge
voilà donc aujourd'hui on a une
évolution de la famille et je ne parle
pas des situations voilà
éclatée donc comment peut-on penser que
ce qui s'appliquait ya cinquante ans et
que vous pensez y et efficace puisse
aujourd'hui s'appliquait ajustement des
enfants qui ne sont plus du tout du tout
du tout dans le même contexte
alors ensuite je trouve une autre
contradiction vous avait raillé un peu
bon c
c'est en effet à faire sur ce mot
bienveillance qui circulent et qui
danserait exposé que nous ne sommes pas
non je je je finis je dis vous raillez
sur ce mont bienveillance mais vous vous
revendiquez la bienveillance vis-à-vis
des enseignants voilà alors peut-être
voilà donc je pense que et c'est pas et
je pense que derrière la bienveillance
que qui est parfois préconisée par
rapport aux élèves c'est pas le laxisme
c'est pas dire que tout est bien c'est
pas ses portes et une exigence mais la
portée de la même manière que vous
réclamez pour vous mêmes enseignants
cette bienveillance par rapport à ce que
vous portez et donc après il ya eu des
mots que j'ai trouvé trop forte à
détestation de la discipline est sûr
qu'on n'enseigne pas ça bien sûr que
toujours en est heureusement qu'il ya
des profs qui qui qui font passer cet
cette valorisation de la discipline
qu'ils enseignent qu'ils aiment et
qu'ils veulent et qu'ils veulent
transmettre
bon donc moi je je pense qu'on est
connaît beaucoup dans l'excès est en
tout cas lorsque vous avez parlé de la
minute de silence et que vous avez dit
ce que d'autres ont dit sous d'autres
formes qu'elle était mal comprise et
partagée et vous mais vous avez 10 par
rapport aux déshérités non pas par
rapport aux déshérités par rapport aussi
à ce que la problématique d'un
adolescent qui ne comprend pas que tout
d'un coup on lui donne une injonction 6
a pas été
conte banier et qui bien que c'est le
propre d'un adolescent se révoltent
déshérités ou pas merci madame pérol
dumont
je vais être relativement bref parce que
je pourrai reprendre quasiment
intégralement hormis le côté joyeux cas
évoqués monsieur longuet sur le sur
votre intervention
je pourrais reprendre intégralement les
propos de monsieur longuet et de madame
cartron je les partage tout à fait votre
un peu partagé un certain nombre des
constats que vous avez posé trop
d'élèves dans les classes pour vraiment
personnaliser l'enseignement etc
nécessité d'une autorité vrai rôle au
chef d'établissement
j'en passe on peut adhérer un certain
nombre de points pour autant et je
verrai sans doute une question
générationnelle dans la proche qui est
la vôtre de la situation dans
l'éducation nationale il se trouve que
nous sommes sénateurs sénatrice c'est
une fonction politique ce n'est pas nos
métiers nous avons tous des métiers par
ailleurs que nous avons exercé souvent
jusqu'à il ya très peu sauf qu'il ya
quelques enseignants du supérieur du
secondaire etc et nous ne nous sommes
pas retrouvés totalement dans les
constats que vous avez fait je passerai
je passerai sur quand même certaines de
vos commandes et antinomie dans vos
propos elles ont été relevées par mes
collègues
enfin dites moi vous êtes fonctionnaire
les enseignants sont des fonctionnaires
ils ont une éthique de conviction mais
il ya une éthique de responsabilité des
enseignants ce ne sont pas des libéraux
et quand vous dites actuellement on est
dans l'atteinte à la liberté pédagogique
on m'oblige à travailler en équipe c'est
nier ma réalité de professeurs mais ce
n'est pas vrai monsieur ce n'est pas
vrai ce n'est pas comme ça que nous
sommes nombreux à concevoir le métier
d'enseignant
l'enseignant c'est pas une singularité
devant une classe c'est ça mais c'est
bien autre chose il faut qu'il y ait les
transversalités il faut qu effectivement
cette émancipation qui est le rôle de
l'école elle soit aussi construite dans
une collégialité
parce que nul n'a la comment dirais-je
l'intégralité de la possibilité
d'émancipation
savourez donc dire que vous êtes contre
le fait que certains enseignants
aujourd'hui justement pour faire face
aux difficultés travailler ensemble que
des profs de philo travaille avec des
prof de biologie pour bien montrer que
tout cela est corrélé
alors j'avoue que je n'ai pas suivi
votre propos donc j'aimerais que si vous
aimez sociale ou ne précise y ait un
petit peu parce que moi à la fin de
votre propos j'ai l'impression que
l'homme est une espèce raté et la vie
une cause perdue ont pas du tout une
question encore sans reprendre hui je
crois qu'en la crêperie justement que
donc très besoin de l'explication
technique du coup je me plais fuji un
peu dans le technique partageant un peu
les points de vue des uns et des autres
alors vous avez dit qu' il fallait plus
de lecture qui est un problème de de
vocabulaire et et que nous ne en tous
les cas que je ne conteste pas et qu'il
y avait des problèmes de graphie alors
le souci dans l'école élémentaire c'est
que le et lydia lee eun qui inspectent
qui l a détecté pour que ce soit sur que
tel point de vue or il y a beaucoup
d'enseignants qui prennent en charge
totalement l'élève et qui acceptent de
commettre l'élève à niveau mais qui ne
vont pas bien se faire peut voir de
l'insp et à l'inspection
alors comment faire puisque nous voulons
tous que les élèves sachent lire qu'il
s'agit pas que les âmes est suffisamment
de de vocabulaire et qu'il sache écrire
c'est c'était vrai c'est trois choses
sont frais verrou de dire archer
merci beaucoup donc voilà vous avez un
quart d'heure pour répondre à toutes ces
questions je fais dans l'ordre voilà
évidemment je me suis très provocateur
quand tu fais parler des valeurs
républicaines qu'il ne fallait pas
transmettre arrêté je me réfère à
condorcet parce que s'il faut penser
l'école républicaine il faut pas se
référer à vue
ferry faudrait plutôt se référer à
condorcet j'espère que vous avez invité
catherine kintzler je sais pas si vous
l'invitez notre commission je vous le
recommande puisqu'elle est spécialiste
de condorcet et condorcet expliqué que
l'école avait vocation à émanciper et
que la république n'était pas une donnée
universel permanente au contraire que la
république devait sans cesse se
réinventer donc c'est très très beau de
lire ça sous la plume de condorcet et
quand je parle de quand je parle de ces
valeurs c'est parce que je me méfie du
moulin du mot valeur de ce qu'on peut y
mettre
rien de plus voilà et que l'école elle
doit permettre à l'air aiguilles de se
réinventer sans cesse donc j'espère que
j'attendais un peu à votre question en
partie voilà bien sûr bien sûr toujours
à conquérir et arrco elle vous parliez
de l'organisation qui a de la
contradiction qu'il y avait dans mon
propos entre voilà cette volonté de
bienveillance j'ai relevé ça ne vaut
intervention à l'égard des professeurs
bien entendu enfin je serai je vais
prouver la plus grande honte à ne pas
être bienveillants à l'égard de mes
élèves je pense que tous mes collègues
et prouve la même chose et imaginer la
violence que c'est pour nous de vouloir
nous dire il va falloir que l'école
devienne bienveillante
elle est nous sommes bien rien nous
voulons le bien de nos enfants un de ses
élèves qui sont devant nous donc vouloir
nous imposer cette liste ce message de
bienveillance c'est porter atteinte à
notre dignité
c'est pour ça que ce message et et
terrifiant parce que c'est une façon de
plus de jeter l'opprobre sur le sur les
professeurs de la république sur
l'organisation qui me séduirait le plus
je suis à vous je suis pas je ne suis
pas je suis là pour alerter ou observer
stats et je suis pas dans un mystère
quoi que ce soit je vous ai donné des
petites pistes sur la façon moi je rêve
d'une école ou au moins dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire les élèves
bénéficierait du même horaire des mêmes
conditions d'enseignement qui était
celle du collège avant le collège unique
puisque nous n'avons pas les moyens de
notre école actuelle c'est un peu ce qui
se passe faisons au moins cet effort
faisons un effort terrible pour que dans
les quartiers qui sont les quartiers
déshérités
on est des on est les rased qu'on ait
des accompagnants qu'on est des
professeurs plus de professeurs par
classe mais dans la réalité qu'on ait
des professeurs qui est aussi un frein
services de certifier en 1975 en 6e
c'était deux classes de 6e en 1975 vous
pouviez connaître vos élèves
vous pouviez vous pouviez voir vous
vouliez les suivre vous pouviez voir
éventuellement des ans ils seraient
légalisées c'était facile aujourd'hui
vous avez quatre ou cinq classes avec un
service de certifier comment vous voulez
avec 100 ou 120 élèves
vous pouvez avoir un suivi personnalisé
tout en ayant cette injonction à la
personnalisation
voilà donc ça je souhaiterais s'il
fallait qu'il est une priorité dans les
eps et serait-ce cet effort
extraordinaire vers l'apprentissage du
français et qu'on revienne aussi sur
ceux moins d'écoles qui est le moins
d'écoles actuelle nous sommes passés
avec la journée vers la semaine des
quatre jours
à 24 heures de cours en primaire en
revenant à la semaine de quatre jours et
demi 1 pour une réforme dont on se
demande
bon bref nous aide nous sommes restés à
24 heures nous sommes restés à 24 heures
c'est le plus bas horaires de l'histoire
de la république en primaire et on
s'étonne que les élèves ne sache pas
grand chose et on leur impose de
l'anglais on leur impose de l'histoire
des arts on leur demande maintenant de
faire du code informatique
c'est la nouvelle lubie mais comment
voulez vous que ça fonctionne comment
voulez vous que ça fonctionne c'est pas
possible
pour répondre à votre question alors je
suis pas nostalgique je suis tournée
vers demain l'école d'hier ne
m'intéresse pas je ne pense pas que
cette école je sais pas des années 30 ou
des années 50 qui était inégalitaire qui
était sexiste qui était nationaliste
dans les années 30 elle ne fait pas
envie pas du tout mais il y avait
certainement des choses qu'on peut aller
y chercher le respect du maître bien sûr
l'autorité la confiance qu'on pouvait
avoir en lui bien sûr on voit pas
pourquoi on devrait y renoncer
la capacité à enseigner la lecture et
l'écriture très vite jean zay
s'inquiétait d'élèves qui ne
maîtrisaient pas lecture fluide en
sortant du ce2 aujourd'hui on a des
élèves qui sont au lycée qui ne la
maîtrisent pas et il faudrait renoncer à
ça parce que c'est vieux non il n'y a
pas de raison c'est un objectif qui doit
rester permanent l'émancipation elle
commence par
à l'apprentissage de la lecture de
l'écriture et pas de la lecture de la
façon d'amener ça c'est la première
étape mais la lecture fluide et la
lecture qui comprend ce qu'elle comprend
pas ce qu'elle lit la détestation de la
discipline nous sommes actuellement en
train de connaître une réforme du
collège et les atteintes qui sont
portées aux disciplines sont terribles
puisqu'il s'agit de réduire encore voyez
je m'inflige est déjà j'ai des
réductions des horaires disciplinaires
ont réduit encore ses horaires dans le
projet de réforme qui actuellement
discutée vous vous pensez vraiment
j'invente que je suis dans le
l'invention non je suis dans le constat
j'observe cette détestation il faut
confiant il faut faire confiance aux
professeurs et pour enchaîner avec ce
que vous disiez je ne me pose pas au
travail en équipe enfin ça mais ça
serait absurde
enfin je dis simplement je dis
simplement on ne doit pas l'imposer
le travail en équipe c'est un travail
qui doit reposer sur la confiance de
l'enseignant telle qu'elle est tel qu'il
est conçu ce travail en équipe est
d'ailleurs tel qu'il est déjà été plus
ou moins imposée par le passé dans
l'école c'était un travail en équipe qui
était qui venait d'en haut en quelque
sorte où on faisait pas confiance à
l'enseignant ont estimé qu'il était
insuffisant au fond fait confiance à
l'enseignant et les transversalités il
les fait bien entendu un professeur qui
au faîte de sa matière est parfaitement
capable de faire le lien entre plusieurs
matières fait mais il faut alors est-ce
qu'il faut l'organiser
moi je j'estime que dans les moyens qui
sont ceux de l'école actuelle on n'a pas
les moyens proférées le payer professeur
vous faire suffisamment de cours est ce
qu'on a vraiment les moyens de dégager
du temps pour organiser des ateliers qui
vont durer six mois parce que c'est un
peu ce qu'on est en train de réparer les
ateliers les enseignements pratiques
interdisciplinaire ce sont des projets
d'une heure et demie ponctuelles qui
vont dévorer une énergie folle chez les
professeurs et les empêcher de
finalement d'assurer leur travail pour
disciplinaires dans leur propre
discipline je vais vous donner un
exemple d'interdisciplinarité qui peu
absurde
j'ai lu ça il n'y a pas très longtemps
ont donné comme exemple regarder un
tableau de représentants narcisse se
mirant dans l'eau très bien et bien si
on faisait une interdisciplinarité avec
les mathématiques comme ça on va pouvoir
observer la symétrie axiale mais c'est
absurde
quel est le sens d'étudier la symétrie
axiale dans un tableau avec narcisse
quel sens ça on fait on veut donner du
sens on fait du factice le sens devient
des disciplines le sens vient des
disciplines qui sont professé
approfondie et enfin maîtrisée par les
élèves
rien de plus pour les inspections pour
répondre à votre question je suis le
premier attristé par le sort qui est
fait aux enseignants du primaire
je suis attristé par ce qu'ils sont ils
sont les ondes et paye qui sont indignes
ils sont ils sont surveillés ils sont
c'est terrible c'est terrible je suis je
suis le premier ils sont obligés de
faire des cours en secret c'est
terrifiant
on les recrute de manière de plus en
plus difficile aujourd'hui beaucoup sont
opposés pour un exemple très simple les
rythmes les a dépossédés de leur classe
l'anglais on les dépossède de leur
discipline voyons on est dans le factice
on dit il faut être pluridisciplinaire
vous connaissez rien à l'anglais vous
allez l'enseigné c'est catastrophique
vous imaginez bien d'ailleurs si vous
regardez les derniers chiffres des
évaluations sur le niveau de langue des
vidéos type des petits français qui
sortent maintenant d'une école qui les a
formés à l'anglais depuis le cp
maintenant ça a commencé en cm2 pour le
cp un peu plus tard finalement notre
niveau de langue les petits français ne
fait que baisser
on a voulu voilà avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre le français et
l'anglais on a rien à la fin rien
j'avais pas compris courant secret mais
ce sont les organismes parallèle avec ce
corps en secret je me disais mais qui
donne encore son nom
on n'aurait pas compris donc je veux
bien mais explicite je m'explique si ces
propos les courants secret ça veut dire
les cours qui ne sont pas affichés sur
le rapport qu'on va faire à son
inspectrice par exemple 1
j'en prends toujours ça veut dire qu'on
va pas faire exactement ce que
préconisent les programmes bat pas on va
passer beaucoup moins de temps à faire
de l'anglais
on va passer beaucoup moins de temps à
faire de l'histoire des arts et on va
essayer de systématiser les
apprentissages d'accord ça va aider
vraiment rien compris
voilà désolé j'avais été très remuant
non mais écoutez chers collègues s qui a
une dernière question puisqu'il nous
reste 5 minutes donc si la bombe écouter
alors j'ai peut-être une dernière marée
dans que j'allais vous dévoile à la
conclusion on vous reviennent la
nouvelle alors j'ai pas fait l'étude ce
que tout ce qu'on pourrait appeler les
nouvelles pédagogies qui en réalité sont
maintenant un peu anciennes qui sont
entrés dans l'école on pourrait faire un
portrait je m'aperçois puisque c'est un
peu la chose qui m'intéresse
actuellement que le numérique tel qu'il
est tel qu'on veut le faire entrer dans
l'école est une façon de rien réactiver
toutes ces pédagogique que j'estime même
à mes yeux nocives le constructivisme le
socioconstructivisme la pédagogie
nécessairement par projet le la
ludification on est en train d'aller
encore plus loin que ce qu'on a fait à
mesure va dans le mur
je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret parce que je finis par quelque
chose de très concret il y actuellement
un dispositif qui a été mis en place par
le ministère qui s'appelle d'école
d'école presque ça pourrait être un des
privatif
si on réfléchit bien d'école c'est en
gros permettre des élèves dans les
établissements défavorisés de bénéficier
n'ont pas de professeur supplémentaire
non pas deux heures de soutien n'ont pas
d'accompagnement par des surveillants
qui seraient formés à cet effet nom
d'école c'est mettre les enfants en face
à des ordinateurs en face d'une
interface du cned
voilà ce qu'on est en train de faire
dans les quartiers défavorisés
ce dispositif est une honte mais
malheureusement il n'est que
l'illustration
qu'est ce qui n'est pas vrai
le processus d'école elle attendait non
en laisse juste finir décoller je vous
redonne la parole je sentais bien que
j'estime honteux qu'on disait des élèves
vous êtes en difficulté allez sur le
site du cned c'est pas la mission de
l'école de l'afrique
alors madame pérol du mans je vous
redonne la parole on peut on peut
vouloir être provocateur ça stimule
l'esprit ça fait évoluer les discussions
et c'est très positif mais trop peu
n'est pas mesure et tout ce qui est
excessif est numérique pas dérisoire est
excessif d'école et c'est excessif nous
sommes un certain nombre à être aussi lu
locaux chefs d'exécutifs et donc à
fournir des ordinateurs à des
établissements scolaires aux écoles
primaires quand on est mère au collège
quand on est président de département
aux régions quand on est président de
région et nous avons un petit suivi nous
avons des liens avec le milieu éducatif
vous êtes monsieur le premier enseignant
le premier et je rencontre régulièrement
et je suis moi même enseignante qui
tient de tels propos
par rapport à l'informatique nouvelles
technologies qui ne sont pas du tout des
fichiers que les i teco qu'on ne
préconise pas comme un substitut aux
professeurs mais comme un complément
parce qu'on en pense ce que l'on veut
mais les enfants baignent dans ce milieu
là et vous leur faire en sorte que
l'école soit un endroit coupé de la
réalité extérieure de la vie des enfants
serait un leurre et un grand danger me
semble-t-il
alors je vous remercie ge pose que nous
aurons donc des suites à donner dans nos
entretiens avec les professeurs au moins
vous nous avez amené d'un questionnement
un petit peu différent de ce que nous
avions jusqu'à présent et ce qui nous
permettra lorsque nous continuerons à
aller sur le terrain puisque nous allons
continuer à y aller à poser ce genre de
question je vous remets